KOTOE KARASAWA:
Doobdoo is a website
that connects pet
sitters and pet
lovers to people who own pets.
And sometimes we need to
travel, and you need someone
to take care of your pets.
That's what we do.
RICARDO FIGUEIREDO: Designing
a little box that you
could take a bag, so you
can wrap up your dog's poop.
And it's a way of
giving people something.
They're going to say, oh,
OK, Doobdoo, what's that?
I'm going to check that out.
I don't know.
It's just like we have
these little ideas.
We can make events, like dog
meetings and stuff like that.
KOTOE KARASAWA: The
biggest challenge, I think,
would be validating the
model and actually validating
the website or the
buttons or the way
the website is
working right now.
If it's working,
if the users are
doing what we want them to do,
and if we are really solving
their problems, that's
the biggest challenge.
RICARDO FIGUEIREDO:
For me, launching
means that I'm going
to test my website.
It's not, OK, work is
done, and it's all good.
Let's just sit and wait.
So launching, for me,
it's a very special stage,
because we're going to get the
early adopters, the people who
really want to know about it.
And these are the
potential people
who are going to share it.